everyone Scott here with a GameSpot news
update so it turns out that the next
version of Call of Duty for last gen
consoles won't have a single-player
component that's right PlayStation 3 and
Xbox 360 versions of call of duty black
ops 3 will only have zombies and
multiplayer Activision said in their
statement call of duty black ops 3 is a
truly next-generation experience
designed from day one to harness the
full potential of the PlayStation 4 Xbox
one and PC the ambitious scope of the 1
to 4 player co-op campaign design of the
ps4 Xbox one and PC versions could not
be faithfully recreated on old
generation Hardware the last gen
versions of the game are selling for 50
dollars instead of 60 and come with a
free version of the original call of
duty black ops the last generation
version of black ops 3 is being
developed by V Knox and mercenary
technology not principal technology
developer Treyarch studios black ops 3
is set to release on November 6th for
all platforms this might be bad news for
some players who like to make their
yearly run through the campaign but for
others it may not matter but once you
weigh in in the comments and let us know
if it matters to you and in the meantime
tune in to GameSpot for more news and
updates